[Music]
after an afternoon playing video games
it is time to take a break and watch TV
and you will be happy to hear that your
favorite characters followed you on
television you won't get to control them
this time but this is what makes the
story even more surprising will your
favorite game be a part of our list if
this is your first time visiting our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
sit back as we show you the 10 video
games that became cartoons Angry Birds
since 2009 we've been shooting birds on
fortresses to save their eggs from green
colored pigs this doesn't make much
sense but when you don't ask too many
questions this is a really fun game to
play some birds had different powers as
the black bird could make everything
blow up the yellow one could speed up
and the blue could split into three
separated birds but how can we turn this
into a cartoon in the new movie the
Angry Birds movie we understood the
reason why the birds were so angry
every bird used to be happy on the
island until the pigs came and stole
their eggs red who had a temper issue
decided to do something about it he told
everyone to stop being so nice and fight
for what they want this is how the birds
discovered their reaction could become a
superpower if they used it in the best
way even the greatest hero gets a little
angry sometimes and there's nothing
wrong with that and if you want more you
can also watch them on television Angry
Bird toons is a TV series based on the
game but there is also a stop-motion
animated series called piggy tails and
another series Angry Birds Stella
telling the stories of Stella's life the
fans can't get enough of these birds and
neither do we Mario Brothers this video
game franchise is probably the most
popular of all time Mario first appeared
in Donkey Kong in 1981 originally known
as jump man and since that day we had
the chance to see him in more than 200
video games as the protagonist the mean
guy or the supporting character Mario
used to be a carpenter but now he's
always risking his life to save Princess
Peach who has been kidnapped once again
by Bowser but what is he up to as a
cartoon our favorite video game
character was actually part of six
television shows but Super Mario World
is
we the most memorable in this universe
based on the game Mario Luigi and the
Princess Toadstool lived in Dinosaur
Land as usual the princess was kidnapped
by King Koopa but the story was more
focused on a little green creature Luigi
found Yoshi and decided to raise him as
a pet the TV series was full of
surprises and what we loved the most was
seeing all these references to the video
game the two brothers had to face the
same monsters and escaped in the tubes
but no matter what happened Yoshi was
always there to save the situation by
eating everything because he was too
hungry but we have to admit that only
the video games were good enough to stay
in our hearts forever
Sonic the Hedgehog since 1991 the
Hedgehog has been the fastest thing
alive with his friends Amy Tails and
Knuckles he spent around the planet to
battle injustice and dr. Eggman Sonic
loved living a peaceful life but he was
always interrupted by the main
antagonist and had to save the world one
more time and luckily for us we had the
chance to sit back and relax as we were
watching his animated TV series Sonic
was part of six television shows the
most recent one being sonic boom in 2014
in the show the character and his
friends tried to stop dr. Eggman who
wanted to take over an island there was
a lot of action with all the battles but
also a lot of fun their plan often
failed but this is what made us laugh
even more we never got the time to know
the hedgehog because he was always
running away so fast but sonic boom gave
us the chance to know more about Sonic's
personality and his friends the show
lasted for two seasons in more than 100
episodes but there could be a third
season coming soon if you want to see
more of Sonic the Hedgehog while you
wait
he is really active on social media now
that he has time to take a break you can
follow him on Facebook YouTube and
Twitter
this animal is fast when it comes to the
trends of 2017 Carmen Sandiego since the
1980s we had the chance to follow Carmen
Sandiego all around the world with the
series of educational video games we
learned many things about different
cultures as we solved mysteries and if
you didn't have a computer or your
brother was using it you still had the
chance to find her on television the
character was first part of two game
shows for children where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego and then we're in
is Carmen Sandiego kids were asked
questions about geography and history
but if you just wanted to sit back and
relax you could also watch an animated
TV series from 1994 to 1999 where on
earth is Carmen Sandiego once again she
stole landmarks the show's primary goal
was to teach kids about geography and
world culture and you could see even
more of Carmen Sandiego soon in 2017
Netflix bought the rights with the
intention of producing a new animated
series we will get the chance to know
who is Carmen Sandiego and why she
decided to become a super thief the show
will premiere in 2019 so we will have
time to prepare ourselves to go on a new
adventure with her Donkey Kong the first
Donkey Kong was an arcade game released
by Nintendo in 1981 y ou had to save a
damsel in distress who had been
kidnapped by the ape the video games
were so successful that these two
characters had the chance to be the
heroes of their own video games at that
time if your mom confiscated your video
game console you also had the chance to
watch him on TV Donkey Kong Country was
not only a video game but also a TV
series from 1997 to 2000 in this
computer-generated rendition of the
classic game the ape lived on an island
with his sidekick diddy kong it was
funny to see that Donkey Kong wasn't too
smart but he was still the strongest
gorilla thanks to his diet of bananas
together the two friends tried to
protect the crystal coconut as king K
rool was always trying to steal it the
biggest challenge he had to face was
trying not to be distracted by the
luscious candy Kong nothing was to be
taken too seriously but we loved that it
reminded us of one of our favourite
video games there is also a lot of
catchy songs that were stuck in our
heads the show was a big hit in Japan
and it only aired briefly in the United
States The Legend of Zelda this fantasy
action-adventure video game series was
first published in 1986 but you can now
find almost 20 games on Nintendo's major
game consoles linked the hero of the
story was often given the task of
rescuing Princess Zelda and saving her
Kingdom players had the chance to
explore his fantastic universe self
puzzles and fight
if they wanted to discover even more
things they could also watch the cartoon
based on the video game The Legend of
Zelda was a 13 episode animated TV
series that aired in 1989 it was aired
on Friday instead of the Super Mario
Bros TV series that aired during the
rest of the week
Lincoln Princess Zelda were trying to
protect the Triforce of wisdom from
falling into the hands of Ganon we loved
getting to know the princess as we
rarely saw her in the original video
game but unfortunately link was not a
gentleman anymore the hero who used to
be brave and courageous was turned into
an annoying man who just wanted Elda to
kiss him this is part of the reasons why
the legends of Zelda lasted for only one
season so the cartoon was not a success
but things could get better there's a
rumor that Netflix might be working on a
live-action TV series based on Zelda no
one has much information about this but
we hope that link will get another
chance to be a part of a TV show it can
only get better
Digimon the franchise was first created
in 1997 inspired by the Tamagotchis the
virtual pets were monsters living in the
digital world a parallel universe that
was created from Earth's communication
networks this is where the title came
from digital monsters the digimons
teamed up with the humans to save their
world from villains first designed to be
cute these little monsters quickly ended
up being created with a harder edge so
they would be ready to fight but which
came first the video game Digimon world
or the cartoon Digimon Adventure
actually they were both released in 1999
creators were so confident their
Japanese media franchise would work they
didn't mind investing a lot of money in
this idea and they were right to do so
the video game series expanded into
genres like fighting role-playing and
racing but the animated TV series was
even more popular 7 kids were
transported into an alternate universe
the digi world this is where they became
friends with the little creatures and
helps them digivolve the more they got
to know this world the more they
realized that the Digimons were the only
ones who could save both their world and
also ours the show ended in 2003 but it
will stay in our memories forever as one
of our favorite animated series from our
childhood Raving Rabbids
the Raving Rabbids were a video game
franchise spin-off of the Rayman series
first published in 2006 it consisted
mainly of party games but also
platformer games and fighting games the
best way to describe them is their
french name that means idiot rabbits
these crazy little creatures like to
cause havoc and mischief always hurting
themselves or failing to do something
this is why they were the perfect
characters for an animated TV series the
show premiered on Nickelodeon in 2013
seventy-eight seven-minute CG animated
episodes were created and they were
broadcast as 26 half-hour episodes
called
the Rabbids invasion the idea was pretty
simple
the rabbits explored earth and
discovered new things but what we loved
about them is that they managed to turn
any situation into something crazy
they could be mean-spirited against each
other but we knew that they were just
acting like children
fans of physical comedy loved the show
and even adults liked it as the humor
could be enjoyed on many levels the hit
TV show was so popular that Ubisoft even
made a video game based on it
Rabbids invasion the interactive TV show
so the video game inspired the cartoon
and then the TV show inspired the video
game kids are going crazy for these
funny rabbits pac-man this was one of
the first video games ever created in
the 1980s it became a huge hit selling a
hundred thousand units in its first year
the game was simple but addictive a
little character had to eat all the dots
in the maze before the ghost could catch
him the creator's quickly began making
the game more entertaining by adding
characters multiple mazes moving fruits
and a faster gameplay the game was so
popular that in 1982 it was already on
television pac-man was a top rated
cartoon in the United States at the time
pac-man and his family would be minused
and one of them would chomp our pills
and save the day the song pac-man fever
also sold over a million copies at that
time since that TV series was so
successful pac-man also inspired another
animated series decades later in 2013
pac-man and the ghostly adventure in
this new story pac-man save the world
ghost with his friends spiral and sily
unfortunately it wasn't really popular
but that didn't mean that the character
didn't deserve another chance the video
game based on the cartoon was more
successful almost 40 years after its
creation the yellow character is still
more popular than ever
pac-man was awarded the Guinness world
record as the most successful
coin-operated game the cartoon wasn't so
popular but no matter what we loved
having more and more of pac-man pokémon
ash wanted to be the very best like no
one ever was and we can say that he
succeeded the franchise began with video
games for the original Gameboy in 1996
the name was a contraction of pocket
monsters as Pokemon trainers could carry
these little creatures anywhere they
went and be ready to fight the games
were extremely popular from the start
and inspired a cartoon a year after in
1997 in the animated TV series ash
aspired to be the greatest pokemon
trainer in the world but he still had a
lot of work to do becoming friends with
the first Pokemon Pikachu with the help
of his new friends Brock and misty he
travelled the world to catch more little
monsters and train them so they could
win battles but so many people wanted to
be the best - so ash had to face many
enemies like the Team Rocket with almost
a thousand episodes the TV series is
still not over yet with Pokemon Sun and
Moon and if you want more there are also
trading card games movies comic books
toys and the new Pokemon go so you can
play on your smartphone Pokemon is now
the second best-selling video game
franchise right after Mario Brothers all
thanks to the animated TV series that
was so successful and that's it for 10
video games that became cartoons
do you remember watching any of these
shows tell us in the comment section
down below
what was your favorite and for more
stories like this don't forget to
subscribe to the thing and watch 10 kids
cartoon characters reimagined as adults
thanks for watching
you
[Music]